Oh  no it's not funny it's a banana  like resignation welcome everyone of the  66th annual Tony Awards or as we like to  call it Fifty Shades of gay I nothing  wrong with tanning if people get it  reaches home to each his own  I like to tan it's still a very famous  experiment and in fact far more people  have heard about yellow watermelon  students today I'll be doing a tutorial  on the correct way to eat a watermelon  as you can see right here what is he  some sort of car wash no don't eggs have  to be fertilized have a look at that so  even though it's a and so we're standing  out here when they carried him out how  do you look oh you just covered in blood  he was on the stretcher but not fun  overwhelming what if your motions been  um a little bit of everything I mean it  was it was of like a fluke to be honest  you know just running I was